I'm going to see you
know
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
All
Continuing in
authored by
in the third chapter
entitled the chapter regarding the
merits of patience. Not just the merits
of patience. This is the chapter of
patience which means that this chapter
is going to be covering issues of merit,
issues of rulings,
different types of patience, etc. This
is one of the longest chapters in the
entire book. This chapter and the
chapter regarding repentance are two of
the longest chapters in
and rightfully so. Their rulings are
many these two subjects and
their merits are innumerous.
He says
Who
[Silence]
Who was
a habs and navs?
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
Patience
in the Arabic language
is
defined as
confining
a person's self or controlling a
person's self. This is referred to as
patience in the Arabic language.
And
in the legislation of Islam, if we were
to say what is patience, Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala throughout the Quran, our
prophet throughout the Sunnah
sallall.aii wasallam, we're commanded
with patience. What does that mean?
Patience.
Anytime the word patience is used in the
Quran and Sunnah as a command,
it is one of
or more
of three things. Number one, a person
controlling himself
upon
the worship of Allah and the obedience
of Allah.
Number two, a person controlling himself
from the disobedience of Allah. from the
disobedience of Allah. Number three,
a person being patient or controlling
himself
and remaining steadfast
in
and remaining
forbearing
when faced with the decree of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala whether that decree
is difficulty or ease.
And it could be argued
that ease is more difficult to be
patient with than hardship is
because hardship very quickly
reminds a person of his mortality
and of his weakness
and of how much a person really needs
Allah. The illusion of independence
is very thin when a person is
struggling.
But when a person is in a time of ease
and health
and wealth and comfort, the illusion of
independence
becomes much more
much more beguiling and much more
illusory.
And so
these three things, whenever we find
Allah's commanding patience in the
Quran, it's one of or all three or more
of these three things. Patience upon the
obedience of Allah. Patience from the
disobedience of Allah. Patience
with the decree of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. Whatever Allah has willed upon
you. Whatever Allah has willed upon us
of illness or health or fragility or
strength
or wealth or poverty. All of this takes
patience.
There is a shared
a shared definition
between linguistic patience, meaning
patience in the Arabic language, and
legislative patience,
meaning patience
as meant in the terminology used in the
Quran and Sunnah.
Most of the time, not always, but most
of the time, the Arabic language,
its definition
of any particular word
is going to be
either
more concise or more broad in its
meaning than the legislative meaning.
But sometimes they can mean exactly the
same thing on occasion.
So here we see that we have the chapter
of patience.
Patience
and a
in the Arabic language is also a type of
fruit that's in the desert. But this
fruit is very sour.
Hence the statement
Here
[Silence]
we have the closing verse of surahal
verse number 200. Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala calls out to the believers. He
says, "Oh you who have believed,
be patient."
So he uses the word
meaning be patient, exercise patience.
And
means
patience specifically
in the face of a patient enemy.
meaning exercising patience
in the face of a patient enemy. Why?
What is victory?
What is a fight? What is a battle? A
battle is a battle of wills. That's what
it really breaks down to.
And patience.
When Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala commands
us with patience, he says, "Be patient."
Meaning, be patient in yourselves.
meaning be patient specifically
in face of your enemies. Your enemies
are trying to be more patient than you
on the battlefield. Who wins? Those who
are more patient. Those who can be can
outpatient the other side. Even if it's
by one moment, just one moment of
additional patience, that is the person
who walks away with victory. And so we
have
So,
[Silence]
and this is most
this issue of al-Sab
most applies to our conflict with the
ultimate aggressor and enemy of the
human being which is El.
What is our battle with El? Our war with
El? It's a collection of battles. Who
wins each of those battles?
Those of us who are able to be even a
moment more patient than our whisperers.
That's the one who wins. And so we are
exhibiting patience not only in
ourselves but patience in the face
specifically in the face of our enemies.
Whatever our enemy is, whether it's the
enemy on the battlefield, the physical
battlefield, or our enemies on the
spiritual battlefield, or our enemies on
the on the belief battlefield, meaning
with those who are hyp with hypocrisy.
That is another type of battlefield.
And it's said that the battlefields of
the human being are four four types of
battlefields.
Either way, we are to exhibit patience
and patience specifically
in battle in meeting our enemies.
We will continue with this topic
[Arabic recitation]